foreign
let's go to Mel in San Francisco
California what's up Mel
hi thank you for having me of course
thank you for calling what are you doing
so I struggled with an eating disorder
in secret for a majority of my teen
years
um I'm currently 20 and I'm fully
recovered but I notice that I'm still
generally unhappy and I've started to to
wonder if recovering from the eating
disorder was only treating the symptom
and not the root problem when I look
back on my younger years
I feel like I never really knew how to
relax I was always in my head yeah yeah
so I I guess my overall question is what
steps do I need to take to start feeling
genuinely happy
hmm
home life was hard huh
um I feel like
some reason I
I think the the problem was socially I
always felt
like nobody really understood me even
back in like Elementary School
common I don't want to throw shade at
your home life okay
yeah a common
root of what you just said is people
don't get me
generally start starts at home
and that can look everywhere from don't
do that like nobody wants I don't have
time to look at your drawings or why are
you dressed like that or quit dancing
and singing so loud it can be any number
of
small quiet things that are trying to
keep peace and otherwise peaceful nice
facade home
and what you learn at a young age is I
need to control me I need to shut this
machine down
and that's a really tall order for a kid
and then often that stuff leaks out of
school and then people at school call
you weirdo or call you whatever kid and
suddenly
whoa
now I'm not telling you that's your
story I'm telling you if I was a betting
man I would put my money there I might
be wrong I may lose that bet
now you're 20. what does recovery look
like now
oh yeah so in high school I had a lot of
really bad eating and exercise habits
and now I feel like I don't resort to
those things when I'm feeling down
but
emotionally I feel like I'm not in that
much of a better place
how did you who worked with you to get
to this place
yeah when I was
I was a therapist and a dietitian for
about a year
and then I moved out of the house and
from that point
um I was able to eat more regularly and
move on from those bad habits
so before we get into the what comes
next
I want you to be able to Exhale for a
second
so take a big big inhale and hold it
like as big as you deep as you can
and hold it for the count of one
two three then let it out what I want
you to pull your shoulders down as far
as they'll go okay
you've done a really extraordinary thing
a powerful extraordinary unbelievable
thing
and so someone who's just meeting you
for the first time
I need you to hear me say I can feel the
strength and resilience on you
okay thank you
and
I think that chasing happiness the
quote-unquote pursuit of happiness is a
dreadful journey to go on
and here's what I mean by that
if I'm chasing happy that I'm chasing
feeling good
and if I'm chasing feeling good
then ultimately I start chasing not
feeling bad and if I start chasing not
feeling bad I start chasing not being
uncomfortable
and there is no growth without
discomfort
there's no achieving a purpose or
achieving goals or having deep wonderful
meaningful relationships without
discomfort
and so one of the great cultural lies
we've been told is that
not feeling uncomfortable is the goal
not feeling
um sad is the goal not feeling
frustrated or mad or angry is the goal
and we duct tape over everything and we
professionalize everything so we don't
have to see death and we don't have to
see discomfort and we don't even have to
have hard conversations with our friends
we just have them with our therapist
everything's become professionalized and
all of a sudden we have found ourselves
in these comfortable chairs in the
middle of a life that's going nowhere
and our bodies are shutting down on us
so what I want to challenge you is to
not make happy The Benchmark I want to
challenge you that pers purpose is your
benchmark where do you want to go where
do you want to be what what lights you
up inside
how do you the the Old Frederick beekner
what's the great need in the world that
brings you Joy that that crystallizes
your purpose that you can cross I mean
you just have that that perfect XY axis
match
what is it what lights you up
um I've been writing some
about seven years
and you're currently I'm writing fiction
novels and I feel like I've always been
an overachiever and I've always known
what I've wanted to do with my life and
I've had that sense of purpose
but
I and I guess I'm going in that
direction
I don't know if anything's changed in
terms of how I feel about writing as my
career if it if it doesn't make me as
excited as it used to I think it still
does
but I do feel like I'm
I'm pursuing what I want to pursue but
maybe I want to pull it apart let's pull
it apart why do you love running okay
okay why do you love riding
um
it's kind of hard to know I I started
when I was really young and for some
reason I haven't stopped do you love it
because you get to find it I get to
create worlds and then inhabit them do
you love it because you like the
reaction people give you when they read
your work do you like the
um like the discipline of having to get
up and write every day what are the
things that bring you Joy about it
um I enjoy the therapeutic nature of it
just also having a routine
um like waking up having my coffee
writing
um and I do also enjoy other people
reading my work and writing reviews or
telling me they enjoyed it
um I do think that if I was not sharing
my work I probably wouldn't be writing
so that's the very big thing for me I
love that
so let me tell you this so at 16 I think
uh maybe I was 15. I got a job at the
local Burger King
right in my neighborhood and I ended up
working there all the way through High
School even into the first my first year
of college I came back over the summer
and worked there
and I learned in short order
that
it takes about 15 seconds to make
somebody's day or to ruin their day
and people would come in with that
standing in the in the in the that long
lunch rush line and they'd have that
Dead Eye there was no cell phones back
then so it was just this numbed out
staring off into space look
and by just quietly saying hey how's it
going how's your day
there was this conscious Snapback to
reality right and up there goes rabbit
right and so they would they would snap
back to reality and they'd look you in
the eye and be like oh man it's great
today's good or it's not so great and
then I could say I'm so glad it's going
well or tell me about it and this is all
while I'm just ass taking your number
two combo with cheese but no onions
right it's very quick and here's what I
learned
that that made me feel alive
and then I went to college and
ultimately ended up studying education
and I worked with young people for years
until I started I went and studied
counseling and then I started getting
into mental health and now I'm a
freaking YouTuber Mel
like I've got a podcast now
I've had a bunch of different jobs from
Chief student affairs officer at a
billion dollar University to Burger King
Frontline guy but if I pull a thread
across all of those I wanted people to
feel a little better after interacting
with me than when they got there I
wanted people to have a little more
peace a little more joy in their life
and a little more optimism going into
the next their next phase
and so I tell you that to tell you this
you love the routine of writing and you
also love sharing your work with
somebody else
I don't want you to feel the pressure of
that means I have to be a professional
writer for the rest of my life I am one
of those too I write for a living also
that's a hard life it's a hard life
and the place I work at Ramsey we have
our own publishing house I didn't even
have to go get a deal it's a hard just
just writing and deadlines and edits and
sub-edits I was making edits on the way
in on the phone today with an editor
it's hard life my wife is an author it's
a hard life
and
is there some places where you can bring
your talents to help a business that's
struggling to communicate their story
about how they can help somebody's life
into the marketplace is there a place
where you can become a teacher and teach
other kids how to get in touch with
those feelings inside of them is there a
place where you can
Share work with other people or share
stories with people there's a whole line
of counseling called narrative therapy
where you right so I'm telling you not
to tell you this your purpose will be
less in the action and more how you make
other people feel
and more how you are lit up from the
inside out
and all of this is going to have
discomfort along the way
and so I think the real challenge moving
forward is how does Mill make peace with
discomfort
and how does Mel
create structure and I know you can
create structure right a few people can
create structure like you can can
override their innate systems to get a
certain outcome you can do that you're a
gangster at that
how can you become not militant that's
the wrong word but how can you become
very disciplined in here are the things
that I know make me feel better here are
the things that I know bring me joy here
are the things I'm going to do them even
when I don't feel like it
and my my guess is over time your body
begins to shift its default setting
there's a great line and I think it's by
it's by Adler are you one of those old
psychologists um kind of the foundation
Founding Fathers of psychology and it
was this
I thought I could make my clients well
by taking away their anxiety and
depression
and what I found is I just made them
empty
I had to take help them take away their
anxiety and depression but then I had to
fill that back with joy and optimism and
laughter and purpose
and so you've done the incredible thing
of stopping the hard stuff
you're no longer you're no longer
hurting yourself anymore which is
amazing it's so hard to do and if you've
if people have never experienced that it
is truly mind-boggling that you've
pulled this off in the short of time now
amazing
the next question is how do I take that
empty emptiness and fill it up with good
stuff along the way
you see like in in I hope you hear my
voice like I am smiling about it like
this is optimism this is a thing to be
really excited about exploring not
something that should shut us down
it's the adventure of a lifetime does
that make sense
yeah it does that sound like woo-woo
nonsense
it should because it kind of is
I just don't know how I I find those
things that make me happy because I feel
I've
I feel like I have a lot of hobbies but
they don't
excite me that much
or they don't excite me as much as they
used to
that's fantastic they served a role in
your life
maybe your hobby is learning new hobbies
maybe your hobby is for six months at a
time spending time with a group of
wackadoo cooking students and then a
group of wackadoo yoga kids and then a
group of
hey I don't know essential oil salesman
don't don't be one of those or like
whatever somebody who breeds doodle dogs
I don't know what like it it it may be x
and y and z
the thing is if you enter into those
looking for ways that they will complete
you they never will
you're complete
you're good and worth being loved and
you're all of your weirdness and all of
your affictions to all of it it's all
it's you're whole
it's now going to seek those things not
that are going to fill you up and quote
unquote make you happy it's going to be
the things that bring you deep
satisfaction and into relationship with
other people
and so I tell you if you used to do
things that really lit you up and now
they're like man cool give those a ride
man sell your bicycle and go get a
guitar or sell your guitar and go get a
what like whatever the thing is
another thing I'll tell you is this
I would recommend with all of my heart
above all other things
to go get a new counselor
and to say
I went through this time in my life I
really really struggled from distorted
eating and from some pretty
um
uh over exercise exercise addiction and
I'm now in a place where I'm not doing
that anymore
and now I need to practice what comes
next and I've never had to do this
before this is a new territory for me
will you help me practice what's next
you may have some depression in there
you may have your body May respond with
some anxiousness it's just your body
trying to take care of you as you head
into uncharted waters and having a
professional counselor that walks
alongside you is really important during
those times
you're worth being loved and you have
strapped yourself to the Mast dude while
the storms raged and the storms passed
and now there's calm water and now you
can untie yourself from the Mast and say
all right where are we going to go next
get somebody to walk with you
I it's it's an honor to have gotten to
spend some time with you Mel you're
incredible